la invasión rusa ucrania entre en su
séptimo día las tropas de moscú
continúan su brutal avanzada y afirman
haberse tomado el control de la primera
ciudad importante este miércoles son
las fuerzas armadas rusas han tomado la
ciudad de gerzón bajo control total la
infraestructura civil infraestructura
crítica y transporte público funcionan
con normalidad no hay escasez de
comestibles y alimentos básicos
los comandantes militares sean rusos
continúan los diálogos con la
administración de la ciudad y la región
para la manutención de los objetos de
infraestructura social la ley y el orden
y la seguridad a medida que se
intensifica la ofensiva en las grandes
ciudades también se multiplican los
ataques indiscriminados contra objetivos
civiles el martes por la noche los
misiles rusos golpearon 10 edificios
residenciales en zhytomyr hogar de
250.000 personas ubicado a 150
kilómetros al oeste de kiev
un misil alcanzó un edificio residencial
y nuestro segundo hospital hubo varias
bombas
el ejército ucraniano dijo que las
tropas aéreas rusas aterrizaron en la
ciudad oriental de hardcore y atacaron
una universidad y la estación regional
de la policía durante la primera hora
del miércoles provocando enfrentamientos
inmediatos la ciudad también sufrió el
impacto de los bombardeos el pasado
martes en la estratégica ciudad sureña
de mariupol los intensos bombardeos
impidieron que los rescatistas pudieran
evacuar a los heridos según el alcalde y
dejaron sin electricidad a la ciudad
portuaria del mar negro
las sirenas antiaéreas volvieron a sonar
toda la noche en la capital ucraniana
donde horas antes los misiles rusos
alcanzaron la principal torre de
televisión de kiev matando al menos a
cinco personas y dañando el cercano
museo conmemorativo de ba biliar donde
decenas de miles de judíos fueron
asesinados durante el holocausto
mientras tanto el convoy militar ruso de
más de 60 kilómetros permanece al norte
de kiev aunque funcionarios de
inteligencia de eeuu dijeron que es
probable que se detenga debido a la
escasez de combustible y alimentos